m
la promotion 4 de l'académie et d'allant
de la plaine des cafres a réalisé un
clip vidéo dans le cadre de leur projet
collectif ils ont choisi comme thème les
violences conjugales
un sujet qui les touche particulièrement
on a monté un projet tous les tirs sur
la sensibilisation sur les violences
conjugales
ça parle de violence wozniacki peut
avoir la réunion et des faits
d'actualité récent depuis le début de
l'année parce que ça touche beaucoup
vêtus de blouses heures des dalons et
que ça nous a touchés on a voulu
défendre cette gosse pour notre collègue
et à la réunion le nombre de plaintes
constatée pour des violences conjugales
et de cinq par jour des violences qui
comprennent différents types
d'agressions y'en à la violence verbale
place et les insultes mais le
rabaissement économique
c'est quand on oblige le conjoint ou la
conjointe à mettre toute façon au
financement sur son propre continent
la violence sexuelle obligé la conjointe
de ceux de faire des actes sexuels sans
son accord
un clip vidéo dans lequel les dalons
sont à la fois acteur et porteur de ce
message de prévention
un projet qui leur a permis de se mettre
en situation de créativité et d'acquérir
de nouvelles compétences
tout d'abord on a commencé à rechercher
des partenaires on a eu des différents
comités d'animation technique et
administratif puis a eu des phases
d'écriture du steak ce scénario puis à
la phase d'enregistrement du son le
tournage du clip
il ya eu aussi le montage est bien
finalisation le clip est diffusé
aujourd'hui
mais il a utilisé beaucoup d'émotion
aussi parce que ben sanou source billy's
et j'espère que le message sera passé
et ben voilà osé briser le silence en
2015 la promotion 3 de l'académie des
talons avait peut aussi réaliser un clip
sur les accidents de la route
leur vidéo a fait plus de 17000 vu sur
internet
une réussite à laquelle il ne
s'attendait pas ben on sait attendu à
que ce soit qu'on a parlé un peu ne
pensez pas une telle ampleur c'est dans
la télé à la radio tout ça donc ça nous
a beaucoup surpris parce qu'on a mis
beaucoup de coeur dans ce projet et on
espère vraiment touché beaucoup de gens
et finalement on a réussi
le déchirent et ça a même été partagé
dans les collèges dans les lycées sur
des projets de sensibilisation routière
c'est avec émotion que les dalles ont
dévoilé leurs clips en avant-première à
leurs familles et proches
ils espèrent à travers cette vidéo faire
passer un message et sensibiliser les
réunionnais